Joe Jonas and his band dnce released a
steamy music video for their new single
body moves on Tuesday that same day Joe
did a reddit AMA and he really did
answer any question ok this is awesome
specifically the 27 year old opened up
about his first time he says he got rid
of his purity ring at age 20 with a girl
named Ashley quote it's pretty easy to
figure out I dated a girl named Ashley
so just google it to figure out which
Ashley that is well that would lead you
to actress Ashley green at Joe's ex
whom he dated when he was 20 it's a huge
night the singer calls losing his v card
a great story not because of what went
down in the bedroom but what happened
leading up to the event apparently Joe
didn't have any condoms so he turned his
roommates room upside down to find one
quote when he came home he thought
somebody broke into his room because his
whole room was demolished because I was
in dire need Joe then adds needed to
happen and then and now safety first
kids
you